we are covering a number of important
developments in american politics first
in congress where senator joe manchin
is wavering yet again on president
biden's massive agenda and that could
throw a big wrench in the democrats
plans meanwhile over at the supreme
court the justices are facing tough
legal questions over that controversial
anti-abortion rights bill in texas
and it is also election day where a key
race in virginia could have national
consequences and we're going to start
there with ed o'keefe who's been
following it all for us ed looks very
close there good morning
good morning tony and welcome to
virginia's largest county we're smiling
through the mass this morning because
nearly 50 people were in line before the
polls opened one woman came in here a
little while ago pumped her fist and
said i'm ready we like to see that kind
of enthusiasm on election day this is
just one governor's race in the southern
state but this contest may give us early
hints of what to expect in elections
next year across the country
wake up virginia here we come let's
bring this baby home
more than 1.1 million estimated early
votes cast in a race between democrat
terry mcauliffe and republican glenn
younkin that poll show is a toss-up
junkin is a wealthy businessman and
first-time candidate we get to stand up
and say no to this left liberal
progressive agenda that's trying to take
us over
no
he's keeping his focus on parental
control of education what we won't do is
teach our children to view everything
through a lens of race youngkin also
appears to be benefiting from an
increasingly unpopular president biden
terry is running against an acolyte of
donald trump mcauliffe is a former
governor and he's running again by
running against donald trump i've beaten
trump twice in virginia tomorrow we go
3-0
he's relentlessly tried tying junk into
the former president by among other
things raising concerns about abortion
rights after texas passed one of the
strictest abortion laws in the country
men like donald trump and glenn younkin
should not be telling women what to do
with their bodies
youngen says he voted for donald trump
last year and although he's avoided
campaigning with the former president
that didn't stop trump from holding a
telephone rally with virginia
republicans last night you got to send a
message to this really corrupt
media the fake news
and all of the people who are destroying
our country
vote for glenn younkin he's going to do
a fantastic job
also today up in new jersey they're
voting for governor and in big cities
across the country from atlanta to
boston cleveland to new york they're
picking new mayors to fill city halls
but again this contest here could be a
big indicator of what to expect because
if we see turnout in a swing state a
blue state where the president's
approval is sagging
it could ultimately give us a good sense
of the result scale it's going to be a
long day
a long day and aren't you up for it i
know you ate your wheaties this morning
ed we'll be counting on you we'll talk
to you a little bit later on